well we're joined now by stuart mckenzie
he's a british citizen who lives in kiev
and he has taken the decision to stay
there stuart thank you so much for
talking to us this afternoon how are you
feeling about everything that's going on
hi kimberly thank you very much um yeah
it's it's it's been a crazy 24 hours um
there's been a lot of uh thoughts and a
lot of the discussions and decisions
trying to be made
yesterday we were hoping that the biden
putin conversation
might create some sort of miracle it
didn't my wife and i took the decision
to to then pack up
we loaded the car we
booked to hotels we organized cash to
leave with her mother her mother-in-law
stays in the house
she's elderly she needs some care we
organized the people there
um
yeah put some jerry cans of extra fuel
in the car went to sleep
didn't sleep particularly well
and this morning you know just before we
were going to go
we couldn't do it we just couldn't leave
uh
where were you going to go stuart we're
going to go to poland i've got an office
in poland and we're going to go to the
border but we couldn't leave the
mother-in-law here my brother's also
here with two children they they didn't
leave i didn't want to leave them behind
we've got we've got thousands of friends
here we've got work colleagues
and and 95 of everybody's staying and uh
we we want to stand by them and and
we're not going to run away from the
bully in the schoolyard we're going to
stay together ukraine's done this before
of course with the orange revolutions
where neighbors
strangers friends all got together and
united they overcome these these these
challenges
so how has it affected you say it's been
it's been um a hectic
24 hours did you say 48 hours but it's
been building for weeks how has it
affected everyday life
everybody's trying to get on with their
lives we'll be at work as normal
tomorrow um like most people will be um
ukrainians are trying their best not to
saber rattle and and and hyped this up
they're trying to continue as peacefully
as possible to go about their normal
daily lives they're not past
you know buying
um
panic buying in the supermarkets or
anything like that it's a beautiful
sunny day here in cave and people are in
the parks and when walking the dogs is
normal um
but certainly when the embassies have
made their decision to leave
the multinational companies
you know they've taken their key staff
and left
um
it's it's just raised the stakes a
little bit um however
we're still talking of a country of 45
million people and big cities like i'm
in today kiev of you know almost 4
million people so together you know
that seems to be the
we don't really feel the immediate
threat of kiev or bombs coming down
uh if that does happen other people have
to make other decisions but is that up
to everybody individually you know some
people have medical issues some people
have young babies some people are
businesses
there's a multitude of decisions that
people have to make individually
how did you feel when the british
government said that british people
living there should get out i mean it
sounds easy doesn't it but you've lived
there for 28 years you can't just pack a
suitcase and get out can you well
exactly i mean imagine it was turned
around the other way and russia was
surrounding the uk just now and i'm the
ambassador and i'm telling you all to
leave
it's not easy right it's your home it's
your life it's everything and you know
why should we leave
right and why should we when the bully
comes in the schoolyard everybody runs
away
no what we do is we get more people like
us to the schoolyard
you know and you know so stop this um
there's easy wins for putin who could
try and take non-mass and things like
this we don't believe people here don't
believe that he's going to come in and
do a mass invasion of a country of 45
million people who don't want them here
um so
yes all support from the uk and other
markets are fantastic in terms of
armors that they can help defend the
country ukraine myself we don't need any
help for you know we don't expect
anybody coming from to our rescue but um
you know we're big boys we'll handle it
the way we can but we're certainly
not going to run away the first
first step
we've spoken to lots of people who um
civilians who've joined up or who say
that if needs be they will fight
have you do you have friends who say
that have you encountered people who say
if we have to we will defend our country
by any means possible
although definitely i know many of them
already that are doing that
um
you remember the maidan
revolutions and then
these guys were out in the street at
minus 20 in the in in hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people
sleeping overnight getting rid of you
know the president and and revolting
against decisions of rushing back
presidents
so um you know ukrainian people will
come together as they have done before
in extraordinary circumstances
and um but yes i definitely know people
that are signing up that are doing
anything possible we'll all do
things what we can do possible the
restaurants will give food the shops
will give clothes you know business
people will give money or services
whatever it's going to be
that's what they do in ukraine what's
the situation like in the shops can you
still get everything that you need
yeah yeah you can't get any bars iron
brew unfortunately but you can get
everything else yes sure it's not
there's no panic buying right now um
there's there's uh there's
everything is quite as normal you know
at the moment
this of course will be
if things escalate part of the problem
with distribution um and getting
products
distributed around the country banking
et cetera but let's again see where that
goes um you've got a whole country here
trying to make sure that the system will
continue to work and no matter what
aggression comes through
and how do people feel about zielinski
we saw him well he's continually
continually said we rely on our people
we rely on our army we saw those war
games just the other day do people
have faith in him do they trust him
yes i think you know i certainly support
what he's saying in terms of keep things
calm
he's the president on the ground of a
country under threat and i think that
the west should listen a little bit more
to the way he wants to deal with it
um rather than keep on
you know saber-rattling from the west
maybe um
he's the one that that he has to deal
with he's the one that's got the best
information on the ground information
and i think yes everybody will support
the president um because he's got the
best interests of the country at heart
so what happens now i'm assuming did you
unpack your car
not yet
it's still half packed we just don't
have the energy really it's it's it's
very emotional
no one can't even imagine what it's like
um
what happens if they do invade stuart
well we'll all make the decision at that
time um you know we've got whatsapp
groups we've got
you know uh
different
social media groups
um that everybody will communicate
through and and decisions will be made
at the time you know we've we've decided
at least that we're staying that's at
least something because when you're
indecisive it can cause a lot of stress
as well so when you made a decision and
then we're gonna we're gonna move from
that position and see how the days and
weeks go by
okay stuart um we understand you're in a
very difficult position to be in thank
you so much for talking to us this
afternoon thank you